outside to that number in some other
countries it's rare to see police and
prison officials protesting they are
considered an essential service
but unions in South Africa say they want
to pressure the government into
addressing the rising cost of living so
you have workers that are slavering on a
day-to-day basis selling their labor and
at the end of the day there's nothing
that they're able to put at the table to
take care of their families workers have
rejected a three percent wage increase
saying it's not enough to help them cope
higher food and fuel prices
the World Bank considers South Africa
one of the most unequal countries in the
world many people here are finding it
hard to make ends meet the economy
doesn't seem to be improving and more
unions are threatening to go on strike
in the coming weeks
South Africa's crippling power cuts are
also fueling public frustration
electricity can go off for hours a day
here reducing business productivity
which could lead to job losses with a
very high levels of unemployment that we
experience in South Africa at the moment
especially if we're looking at around
the 36 Mark looking at economic growth
they're like more common seven percent
economic growth we do not have enough
growth to actually be driving the South
Korean economy the way we need in order
to not only reduce that unemployment but
be able to create sufficient shall we
say jobs or Lifestyles for people to be
able to
survivedi managed to make a few dollars
selling food to some of the
demonstrators she understands why people
are angry
I can't afford rent my kids are at
school there are days I feel hopeless
here
president Sarah ramaphosa is not
attending this week's U.N General
Assembly meeting in New York saying he's
going to tackle the electricity crisis
and other challenges facing the country
it seems Africa's most industrialized
economy is in trouble as more and more
South Africans grow increasingly
frustrated
[Music]